we are here to answer your questions
about your life and your money while the
nation is in the grips of election fever
we're going to talk about something that
actually does affect your life you what
happens at your house is a whole lot
more important to your future than what
happens in the White House last night
Jack nobody in any of these countries
congresses or State sentence or
governor's mansions have sent me any
money I hadn't gotten a check from any
of them unless it was a refund check
there was a portion of what the big
dadgum check I sent them in the first
place
meaning they kept most of it and sent me
a little back make me feel good about
them what happens at your house and how
you control your money is a lot more
important than a lot of stuff that
everybody sitting in squawking about
right now yes I voted yes I believe in
voting but I have never waited on nor
will I wait on a Democrat to change my
life or a Republican to change my life
if you are waiting on the President or a
congressman or a senator or a governor
to change your life you're gonna have a
long wait meanwhile your life is gonna
suck
because they're not gonna change your
life they're not gonna fix your problems
that would be your job boys and girls
it's your job so this is a place where
grown-ups gather around the radio and
we're gonna do grown-up stuff today you
take responsibility for your life and
I'm gonna be your biggest cheerleader
because I'm your biggest fan I want you
to win and I'm gonna give you some
guidelines and some answers to some
questions that hopefully lead you to
winning that's our goal
pretty simple stuff isn't it